[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti per me questa è la
prima volta qui al ted questo bollino
rosso e mentre venivo qui pensavo come
cominciare il mio speech per tutti voi e
volevo cominciare con qualcosa in comune
tra me e voi tra quelli che ci seguono a
casa in streaming ecco vi dico subito
che questa in realtà non è una cosa ma è
un azione
la prima azione che facciamo quando
veniamo al mondo ed è quella di
respirare e sì perché noi in questo
momento tutti quanti noi stiamo
respirando non è che la mattina quando
ci svegliamo diciamo oggi mi devo
ricordare di respirare no non l'ho non
lo ricordiamo non ci facciamo questa
domanda
e anch'io emozioni a parte in questo
momento sto respirando vedete fino a
dieci anni fa io 40 anni fino a dieci
anni fa non mi hanno messo soffermato
sul respiro perché farlo se un'azione
che impariamo quando nasciamo e
continuiamo a farlo per tutta la vita
salvo problemi ovviamente fisici poi in
una giornata di sole milanese mi ero
trasferita da poco a milano l'incontro
un avvocato si chiama anna gerometta e
cominciò a parlare di quanto io fossi
contenta di vivere a milano io arrivata
da un paesino della della campania che
si chiama paesino a bella città normanna
aversa e lei comincia a parlarmi di
quanto in realtà quella città una città
meravigliosa internazionale fosse
inquinata cominciò a parlarmi dell'area
inquinata soprattutto nel nord est
dell'italia e che in realtà non
riguardava più soli nord est ma ormai
quasi tutta l'italia era un po incredula
cominciò a seguirli una organizzazione
no profit che si chiama cittadini per
l'area e cominciamo a monitorare l'aria
l'abbiamo fatto fino all'anno scorso tre
città milano roma napoli sono tre città
perché poi è anche dispendioso farlo e
siamo appunto cittadini bene il biossido
di azoto e superiore anno dopo anno
rispetto alla media che l'organizzazione
l'idea della sanità impone ogni anno
abbiamo quasi 80mila morti premature 15
mila di queste morti è dovuto a biossido
di azoto che un inquinante che arriva
dal viso e delle macchine
tutto questo è vero sì per non parlare
poi della mancata informazione sui danni
che l'inquinamento provoca al sistema
ormonale al sistema polmonare e al
problema cognitivo
per quanto riguarda i bambini l'abbiamo
detto prima quando nasciamo e la prima
cosa che impariamo a fare è quella di
respirare perché noi per nove mesi come
respiriamo
grazie all ombelico della nostra mamma
l'ossigeno della mamma va al bambino ma
che ossigena respirato alla mamma ecco
già da lì cominciano i problemi
80.000 morti premature l'anno sono
troppe quando una persona magari giovane
una donna un uomo giovane se ne vanno
via l'improvviso diciamo un ictus ma
com'è possibile l'inquinamento genera
tutto questo vedete torniamo sempre a
parlare di ciò che respiriamo noi ogni
giorno ormai soprattutto negli ultimi
anni quando compriamo qualcosa da
mangiare prestiamo attenzione ormai a
casa mangiamo perché non prestiamo
attenzione a cosa respiriamo
bill gates recentemente ha dichiarato
che ogni anno 5 vengono praticamente
messe 51 miliardi di co2 che nel 2050
deve essere azzerato missione
impossibile direte no deve essere
possibile per noi è come arriviamo al
come arriviamo al como sicuramente la
tenera la trasformazione tecnologica è
fondamentale in italia già è cominciato
questo percorso anche se un percorso
lento costoso dovremmo e lì noi possiamo
fare poco
dovremo però cominciare a prestare
attenzione alla rigenerazione ambientale
degli spazi e della mobilità
il vero problema se non cominciamo a
capire che parte tutto da lì e dare sola
colpa alla tecnologia che non va di pari
passo
abbiamo fallito rigenerazione di spazio
in mobilità come si fa quanti di voi
quando vanno a votare vedono leggono il
piano ambientale di colui che abbiamo
scelto chi lo fa alzi la mano chi lo fa
perché io non ho il coraggio ad alzarla
perché non l'ho mai fatto
eppure sono anni che voglio capire cosa
respiriamo
sono anni che mi batto nel dire guardate
io ho degli anni 80 a casa già facevo la
raccolta differenziata anche se vivo ad
aversa anche se mi prendevano in giro
perché dicevano ma tanto uniscono tutto
bene
io con la mia coscienza l'avevo fatto
potremmo cominciare già fare quello
perché vedete non è il presidente del
consiglio il presidente italia a fare un
cambiamento nelle nostre città non sono
loro sono i sindaci sono gli assessori
sono loro che hanno la responsabilità di
far cambiare il nostro comportamento
quotidianamente e quindi siamo noi che
li votiamo
non voglio fare per niente politica in
questo momento ma voglio soltanto far
capire che basta dare la colpa agli
altri perché possiamo fare noi in prima
persona qualcosa
ora vi chiedo di fare un respiro
profondo serve anche a me perché non è
facile stare qui davanti a tutti voi
anche se lavora in televisione ma è una
cosa per me nuova diversa sono abituato
a intervistare quindi a far parlare
facciamo respiro profondo
gli facciamo un altro vedete questo
secondo respiro lo dobbiamo all'oceano
perché perché grazie all'oceano e grazie
degli organismi che si fanno parte
dell'oceano che sono nell'oceano con un
sistema di fotosintesi arriva l'ossigeno
a tutti noi così come succede con le
piante sul nostro pianeta è uguale
lo sapevate io no oceano mare perché poi
realtà noi parliamo di mare no parliamo
sempre di limare in realtà è tutto un
unico grande oceano arriva italy
l'ossigeno a di là se viviamo in
montagna in città o in campagna è uguale
respiriamo tutti di là di dove abitiamo
quell'ossigeno e l'oceano prima l'ho
detto ne parliamo di mare ma realtà poi
c'è un è tutto un grandioso e tutto
interconnesso vi faccio vedere questo
filmato si spiega meglio di quanto sia
importante il nostro c'è uno guarda the
principle number one di air one big
ocean way mini features
[Musica]
domande principali elettricista o in
giappone
dio e planet
[Musica]
e tutto il tutto connesso vi racconto
allora la storia di sara una ragazzina
dell'oregon costa ovest dell'america
aveva deciso così e compagni di scuola
di aveva costruito delle piccole
imbarcazioni senza equipaggio per poter
poi trasportare dei doni dei messaggi
fino in giappone bene cosa succede
insomma era un'impresa abbastanza
difficile
eppure ci sono riusciti ci sono riusciti
con le correnti ovviamente anche con la
collaborazione dei piccoli colleghi
nelle altre parti della delle coste
americane e quelle barchette sono
arrivate a destinazione
dovremmo avere infatti una slide con una
barchetta e ti fa vedere tutto il
percorso
ora non è perché voglio raccontare la
storia di questa ragazzina né una mia
parente ma c'è un motivo perché questo
ci fa capire quanto sia tutto
interconnesso barchette costruite da una
bambina di 10 anni
e allora se quelle barchette arrivano e
fanno questo percorso incredibile per
arrivare questo cosa vuol dire che le
correnti tornano sempre
[Musica]
pensate che c'è eccola qui tutto il
percorso di queste barchette pensate che
un signore ha trovato nord della della
francia un vasetto di yogurt voi direte
vabbè quindi incivile chi l'ha buttato
ok quel vasetto di yogurt questo
succedeva l'anno scorso questo vasetto
di yogurt era datato 1976 pazzesco era
intatto sappiamo tutti che ci vogliono
200 anni per per demolire per per
eliminare una bottiglia di plastica e
allora guardate questo dato con me 8,8
milioni di tonnellate di plastica
finiscono nell'oceano l'ottanta per
cento va a nel profondo del mare
e cosa succede vento sole correnti
disintegrano quella plastica che non va
via
no va a finire nell'aria a finire nel
cibo nel miele che mangiamo nel sale
della cucina quando cuciniamo e molto
probabilmente quando noi respiriamo
le correnti fanno un giro quello che
lasciamo torna a noi li ha un impatto
devastante sul nostro sistema ormonale
sul sonno probabilmente anche sull'umore
però vedete se se succede tutto questo
c'è un'altra cosa c'è una risposta molto
bella che arriva dall oceano
l'ottanta per cento delle bio diversità
esistenti sul pianeta sono lì nel mare
questo 80 per cento di biodiversità sono
fondamentali sono un patrimonio pazzesco
perché studiando le si stanno trovando
delle risposte contro malattie terribili
come l'alzheimer come alcuni tipi di
tumore e addirittura ci sono anche delle
ricerche per poter trovare un vaccino
una cura contro i co di byd 19 ma
ricordiamoci che quello che lasciamo
quello ci torna
ecco perché ho deciso lo scorso anno
maggio realtà sembra una vita fa di
avere più tempo libero per me per la mia
famiglia e anche per le cose in cui
credo sono licenziato in un momento dove
manca il lavoro ma l'ho dovuto fare l'ho
dovuto fare per me l'ho dovuto fare per
la prima mia famiglia per quello che io
voglio per il nostro futuro
non potevo stare dieci ore non solo
chiuso in uno studio come questo senza
vedere cosa succedeva fuori di me come
il tempo cosa succedeva le mie figlie e
anche mio marito quando banalmente mi
chiamava e non potevo rispondergli e non
leggo neanche il tempo di informare ed
informarsi
ecco perché ho detto di sì quando
l'unesco mi ha chiamato e mi ha detto di
dedicare del mio tempo per poter
informare per poter essere attiva con
loro perché sta per arrivare un decennio
fondamentale
promosso dalle nazioni unite 2021 2030 e
un decennio fondamentale per il nostro
oceano per quello che respiriamo
guardate
i tuoi matching ex hostess nickname
[Musica]
poi alla domanda se siamo pronti a
questo movimento io spero che tutti noi
rispondiamo di sì perché lo dobbiamo per
me stessi io come mamma lo devo per i
miei figli ma anche come donna
responsabile lo devo perché la casa dove
viviamo non è la nostra casa noi viviamo
nel nostro pianeta nostro non degli
altri quando noi non sappiamo una cosa
non ne diamo il giusto valore e quindi
siamo quasi autorizzati a saccheggiarlo
queste non sono parole mie
sono le parole della leader che popola
huaorani che ha scritto la settimana
scorsa il leader della terra
noi sappiamo non possiamo fare finta di
niente
non possiamo più saccheggiare certo non
bastano dieci minuti di talk a cambiare
le cose
lo so ma queste cose le dobbiamo sapere
dobbiamo ricominciare a pensare che ciò
che ri speriamo la nostra fonte primaria
e fondamentale per tutti noi
nel mio piccolo cerco di farlo
facciamolo insieme ognuno deve fare la
sua parte
grazie
[Musica]